hey guys Ryan right here I just saw the
Marvel vs. DC Avengers battle video but
everyone said I should really check out
by I think you say Rocco Rocco Rocco
Rocco item I don't know they said that I
should check out the Harry Potter versus
Star Wars video I'm hoping this one is
just as good if not better shopping
awesome iPod Touch yeah what
Oh
skin cotton you wish
ah
you use the Force Luke your father
you are the chosen one
instead you attend destroy the Sith not
join them my favorite part was what he
started shouting get up umm I'm not here
to compare the Marvel vs. DC one with
this but if I had to I would say I
enjoyed that one a lot more I mean don't
get me wrong the other one was funny but
this one other one was structured better
I mean obviously not gonna be as chaos
you don't have as many characters I love
their setups of like these nerds who
happen to also be these characters
that's so funny paint tribute to all
these fanboys across the world in such a
great way and what's so cool about their
videos is that the action yeah I mean it
looks cheesy it looks like they just
came up with it on the spot and then he
filmed it but a lot of the time though
it looks pretty cool like that looked
like a legit battle like if I thought a
Jedi and Harry Potter were to go down I
mean in a Hollywood movie a little way
[ __ ] cooler but for like bunch of
people just [ __ ] around with a camera
that looks great that's the main thing I
love about the videos that I've seen in
them so far is that there's such a level
of creativity and spontaneity there that
it feels like these dick guys were just
sitting around talking maybe they
weren't even in a writers room they were
just like joking and then suddenly they
came up with some funny bits and they
turned it into a script and that's what
I love about it is you feel that level
of like guys just having a fun time and
then coming up with something and then
shooting it I mean those are the best
kind of YouTube short films anyway when
it comes to the comedy department at
least for me I mean then you got guys
like college humor who are clearly a lot
more thought-out and you know really get
the script assembled and everything and
I really like that too but I love the
level of fun that these guys have it's
like you feel like you're just hanging
out with these dudes who are just having
a great time same time watching their
creative fart I would love to keep
checking out if you guys have more
videos to recommend by them please send
them my way anyway guys thanks for
telling me that was out if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects and if you follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter get
enough followers we might get product
placement I'm hoping article light will
sponsor me if I can get tickets to arc
light it would be great you know you get
reserved seating you earn enough points
eventually you get to get free [ __ ] you
usually get 5 bucks off concessions by
purchasing not that many tickets it's
really [ __ ] cool and also I got head
one time when I went to arc light and it
was cool because it was reserved seating
so the people next to me couldn't move
away they had to be forced to sit there
and then watch me get a [ __ ] reserved
[ __ ] brian nolasco this guy's
constantly sending me video suggestions
and he did want a shout-out so brian
nolasco here is your shoutout my friend
shoutout to begin look like a youngin
buy this selfie photo that you're taking
alright time to give more children
advice brian nolasco here's what i'll
tell you you might want to start this
young because if you get into this when
you're older it can hurt but if you
start young it could feel really good
and by the time someone actually does it
to you you'll like it put your finger up
your butt like when you're actually
masturbating just shove that finger up
your butthole maybe you have to take it
a little slow maybe don't but just try
it try it and if you like it while
you're touching yourself
keep going doesn't mean you're gay just
means you like rectum pleasure i'm ryan
right have a good day